the most current event on this night is
the lakers game two victory over the
nuggets
lebron james shouldered the scoring load
in the first half anthony davis
took control in the second half when he
scored 22 including the game-winning
three let's hear from the coaches
well obviously huge significance uh
we're up 2-0 now as a result of that
uh just a big-time shot by a big-time
player
and you know we have uh we have a set
where we can
uh basically isolate lebron on a
baseline out of bounds situation like
that
uh ronaldo came up whispered in my ear
about uh
you know do i want him in there as the
passer and um
obviously i said heck yes he made a
great read on it and you know anthony
flew over to the wing
you know he talked about missing that
shot uh that similar type of shot
against brooklyn right before uh the
hiatus and uh
you know like i said big time shot by a
big time player this is the western
conference finals
so no moral victories no silver linings
gave ourselves a chance to win tonight
obviously uh
anthony davis hits a big three to win
the game at the buzzer
so we'll watch the film see what
happened on that last play
and the message is you know we're down
2-0 let's go out and win game three
donovan mitchell reacting to the anthony
davis
buzzer beating three so kevin love
taking you one better hey lakers in
three
just like that we'll miss you in the
playoffs damn get well
yep a lot of uh
eyeballs from the nba on that game
that's for sure
you know what that means that's tough
shoot hey what man cj and dame
on twitter a lot yeah you know what i
mean ernie he's like that
anthony davis was was screaming i'm like
that after that game for those who don't
know
uh last time the lakers had a buzzer
beating
three to win a playoff game
i always say that's the play that should
have never happened well what's he get
because you know robert shouldn't even
been out
there he should be crashing the boards
they're only down once oh
that's the game the ref stole from
sacramento
webber is down there in the bubble right
now saying what are you doing showing us
that oh the sacramento kings
hurts doesn't it yeah wait listen hold
on 18 years ago
18 years ago oh yeah you can't be like
oh
no
the sacramento keys can't be funny on
twitter yes they can no they can't knows
you can't jump in the conversation no
shaq
first of all there are some similarities
no there is it it is
a buzzer-beater that's the only
similarity you need hey
that's the only similarity sacramento
kings have not earned the right to crack
jokes first of all
they lost on the buzzer business
no that's the last time we heard from
them 18 years ago doesn't matter what
happened no you don't they don't get the
crack joke i guess
they do come on you agree with me kenny
100 percent jumping in come on
sacramento kids i'm playing jokes and
you can't jump into
first of all it wasn't a joke it was a
question said it it hurts doesn't it no
no
because they're saying remember us like
we don't
stop no no you can't remember hey
kitties they've been feeling that pain
what'd you just say remember us no we
don't no we don't remember the
sacramento kingdom
i know you don't because big shot bob
hit the shot put him away 105 103
tonight's final
scott bob i love you boy you've talked
about the impact that
nikola jokic had in that game and trying
to will them back let's hear from the
joker
can you describe what the moon in the
locker room is after fighting so hard
and then
obviously the disappointment of that
shot i mean we were there before i think
the second or third game against
clippers i think we had it
and we kind of lost it in the end so uh
we put the effort there we put the fight
um
we lost the game but i think that uh we
played well
uh most of the game uh we were down we
came back again so
[Music]
we're gonna keep our heads up and uh
on to the next one
next we'll go to rick lombardi pick go
ahead
nicola um nicole of losing the way you
did certainly sucks
but do you think he figured something
out on how to defend them
tonight
i mean you know they're
they're two they have two really good
really good really good
players they have a
lebron who is the probably best best
best player
in the league and they have a ad who is
the probably best scorer
in the league so i think it's it's not
easy to figure them
they are really talented we can just
make make them
tougher make them feel uncomfortable so
answer that question maybe but they're
really talented they're gonna
they're gonna find solutions so we just
need to we just need to
kind of stay on top and just
just make them make them uncomfortable
you already heard michael malone say
look there's no moral victors or
anything like that
is there any when you lose a game like
that is there something
positive you look for to try to tell
your guys hey look in game two we did
this well and so in game three
let's do this or yeah yeah
no you don't i i wouldn't be demoralized
at all i would just be
i would be upset we lost but i would say
we we let old men in the first half play
like young men
and we played with no energy we played
with energy in the second half
and it was a game we have to play with
energy in both halves
i had to go down and get pj dosia come
on out
to get energy into the game because you
guys will play
rondo howard you know lebron
these guys are 16 years or more playing
with more energy than guys who were in
the league for five years or less
and he had to go all the way down to pj
dozier to get energy
that would be an upside for me if i was
michael parter jr or monte
morris and those guys saying i'm not
letting them go that far down the bench
anymore to get energy
i'm going to bring energy game three we
get it to 2-1
we'll be like boston sitting there going
what's up let's go next
to game one anyway they got go ahead
shaq sorry after game one they got beat
up
they said okay we know we got to do ken
kenny is right uh first have no energy
second half energy
they lose on the buzzer beater the good
thing for denver is they're used to
coming back
and this team you really have to put
them away because they're in the
locker room saying yeah we had 20
turnovers we didn't have energy in the
first half but we didn't lose that game
a.d just hit a hell of a shot so they're
not going to lose confidence
game three is very pivotal for the
lakers the lakers must put this team
away
if not if you give this team confidence
then you know we
we may have a longer series than
anticipated yeah and i'd be worried if i
was denver i'd be worried about joker
because he is extr he using a lot of
energy
on both ends of the floor because he has
to wrestle with
start out the game with mcgee come in
with dwight and try to guard a.d
and now these games are coming every
other day
there's no traveling no no no no no but
i'm saying though
that's a lot he's got to get 30 like
kenny says
he's got to get close to a triple double
like and guard those three guys
because those three guys you have to put
a body on dwight
and javale and liz he got no chance
against a.d
i would be concerned because it's going
to be a quick turnaround tuesday
105 103. anthony davis wins it for the
lakers
buzzer beating three i'm like that ernie
there you go
[Music]
i'm that guy and the lakers have a
two-zip lead you want me to tell you the
western conference finals
hip-hop